[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos sobre las consecuencias del
golpe d estaban bien mar el pasado lunes
primero de febrero hecho que ha generado
el rechazo internacional de manera
unánime nos acompaña tomás ojea quintana
relator especial de derechos humanos de
la onu de la república popular
democrática de corea y ex relator
especial en mianmar señor ojea quintana
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 como este país del sureste
asiático llegó hasta este punto y además
le pregunto si se esperaba que en algún
punto del liderazgo de anshan su chip
ocurriera un golpe de estado
argumentando según el ejército que la
unión nacional estaba en juego
bueno buenas tardes buenos días a todos
francamente no se esperaba un a una
acción del gobierno de los militares él
me llamara de estas características
había cuestionamientos a el conteo de
los votos de la última elección en el
mes de noviembre del año pasado que el
partido de la señora aún son sus ya
había ganado en forma abrumadora
se cuestionaba que había habido fraude
por parte del partido militar
básicamente pero no se esperaba una toma
del poder por la fuerza por parte de los
militares no obstante recordemos que me
al mar en el pasado sufrió 40 años de
dictadura militar y recién en el 2010
comenzó esta transición democrática con
lo cual es evidente que el poder militar
no se ha reformado continúa
manejando por porciones importantes del
poder y la economía del país y estas son
las consecuencias ahora qué puede pasar
con los políticos detenidos con el
futuro también danzan succi que también
sigue detenida y cuáles son los detalles
de estas acusaciones
este estos 40 años de dictadura militar
causaron serios y gravísimas violaciones
a derechos humanos recordemos que el
miramar se cometió además el genocidio
contra los rohingyas con lo cual hay un
récord de violaciones de derechos
humanos muy muy graves incluida la
detención de presos políticos la señora
nancy y en particular por ejemplo sufrió
más de 12 años de prisión domiciliaria
en el pasado y ahora nuevamente como un
deja vú se encuentra detenida en su en
su domicilio en la comunidad
internacional ha sido categórica en
reclamar que se liberan los presos
políticos y se que se retomen la
transición democrática y que se respeten
los derechos civiles y la libertad de
expresión en el país usted hablaba sobre
un punto muy importante y es sobre la
minoría musulmana rohingya qué pasará
con ellos ahora con los militares en el
poder
es difícil predecir cuál va a ser la
situación en el territorio y la
información que mayor manejo es que se
han acercado los militares a los guetos
donde esta comunidad se encuentra
encerrada literalmente y se le ha dicho
que se queden tranquilos que se les
respetarán sus derechos por el momento
pero la verdad no habiendo mecanismos de
control civil por el momento ya que el
poder está en manos de los militares y
la comunidad rojin ya está realmente
atemorizada por otro lado es cierto que
la comunidad internacional ahora que los
militares han demostrado que no van a
respetar la transición democrática que
todo el pueblo de mi alma desea que todo
el pueblo en miramar desea también en
los acuerdos de paz con las minorías
étnicas en la comunidad nacional va a
ejercer muchísima más presión contra el
gobierno militar veremos que lo que
sucede es muy difícil para decir así es
y por último le pregunto brevemente por
favor la respuesta qué consecuencias
traerá este golpe militar para los
ciudadanos de mar
lamentable lamentables consecuencias
porque todo lo ganado hasta el momento
por la transición democrática realmente
ahora se ha perdido y esperemos que la
comunidad internacional y el pueblo de
mi alma puedan retomar esta transición
para realmente que el país pueda
desarrollarse en las mejores
circunstancias y con la gana
garantizando los derechos de todos
individuos en mi alma
así es señor ojea quintana gracias por
su tiempo por supuesto por estar aquí
con nosotros en france 24 conversábamos
con tomás ojea quintana relator especial
de derechos humanos de la onu de la
república popular democrática de corea y
ex relator especial de especial de
mianmar has aquí cinco minutos con
continúan con nosotros esto es france24
[Música]